hello everybody welcome back to the
matplotlib 3d graph series in this
tutorial video we're gonna be talking
about putting up three-dimensional
scatter plots and then also adding
labels to our plot color and plots look
or feel or whatever you want to call it
with the first video in the 3d series I
just kind of wanted to keep it basic as
possible and then as time goes on we'll
continue adding layers not only to the
you know because basically we're going
over different chart types and then now
we're going to start adding stuff that
is kind of similar like you're gonna
have labels all across and then the
colors and the line type and all this
kind of stuff kind of follows you no
matter what you're doing in a 3d
plotting so that's kind of what I'd like
to do with this 3d series so anyway with
that let's hop right in same things
before we're going to need from NPO
underscore toolkits dot and plot 3d
import axes 3d and then the next thing
we're gonna need is import mat o'clock
live dot pop a lot as PLT done next
thing we want to do a fig equals plot
figure nothing new nothing new axis
equals fig dot add underscore so a lot
nothing new same things before and then
projection equals 3d same thing as
before there as well now we're going to
toss it up a little bit the last time we
what we did was XY Z equals and then
three arrays instead what I'd like to do
if since we're having kind of long
arrays I think that it's better to do x
equals an array y equals an array and
XIV wasn't alright since our data is so
long but I would you know probably in
the at the end of the day you're gonna
end up finally doing like an X Y Z and
equals that numpy array that we had done
in the matplotlib series prior to these
videos so with that this is just another
way to
think about doing it if you do have a
lot of data but chances are if you have
a lot of data you're probably um pulling
from a file or something like you're not
he and typing it in but anyway we're
just going to show you you know there's
multiple ways to do the same thing in
programming and so it's just good to
show the multiple ways to do it
so anyway we're just gonna make up some
data again if you still have your data
from before you can start arranging it
this way or you can leave it the way you
have it it doesn't really matter you
know something like that okay so now we
have what I believe to be 10 of each
hopefully the next thing we want and
this will be a little different it's
gonna be a X dot scatter for scatter
plot and then we're going to do X Y Z to
plot the next thing we have is C for
color and we're gonna say that color is
gonna be real red and then now we have
marker and this there's all kinds of
different markers and in this case we're
going to use the just a zero for like a
circular marker and finally you can also
set labels so we're going to go ahead
and do that so ax dot set underscore and
X label and we're just going to call
this x-axis and then the same thing for
the other ones let's just copy and paste
this saves some time so this will be x y
and z Z Y and X so now the next thing
obviously the plot show
plot shop go to shopping save we'll run
this over you know errors of course we
had errors we need to capitalize the D
it's actually is three capital D for
dimensions let's try again all right
here we go
and we have our plot let me fit it to
screen now you can see that instead of
like lines there you know scatter plots
on the chart and the red in circles and
beautiful we also have our X axes or Y
axes and our z axes labeled here for us
and
the other thing you'll note that's I
think is pretty impressive again it took
quite a bit of coding is this visually
it's very hard for you to tell which
plot is closer this one or this one now
if there were the exact same red that is
but visually you know because this one's
obviously closer as you can see as you
turn it you can see it visually but also
when it's a static chart say you only
took an image of it you'd also know
because this is kind of faded a little
bit so it gives you the the really it's
an illusion that this plot is further
back so as we rotate you know you do see
that it was further back it's still
further back and then as it comes closer
it's it's clear that okay now it's
really close so anyway just a little
subtle things like that I just
definitely impress me I think that's
really awesome for this graphing is so
it's just such a simple little graphing
program and it's really lightweight so
it's just a great great program anyway
that's basically it as far as making
[Music]
three-dimensional scatter plots as
always thanks for watching stay tuned to
the next video and thanks for your
support your subscriptions